[Music]
the agents of the naval criminal
investigative service or ncis often have
to make snap decisions when in the
middle of dangerous and intense
situations whether for the sake of their
colleagues or their country several
characters on the cbs procedural commit
morally ambiguous actions over the
course of its staggering 19 seasons and
400 plus episodes however when the sunny
goth forensics investigator abby played
by paulie pared breaks bad in a season 5
episode many fans consider her behavior
controversial while agents gibbs dinozzo
and david portrayed by mark harmon
michael weatherly and cody depablo
respectively are characters which openly
struggle with personal demons or family
complications abby is a generous and
playful person but everything seems to
take a sudden turn in the episode dog
tags the episode kicks off with the team
executing a warrant on a house only to
find their suspect mauled to death
inside the suspect's dog butch then
attacks agent mcgee portrayed by sean
murray landing a serious bite on his
neck and wrist mcgee defends himself by
non-fatally shooting the canine but
butch's behavior convinces the rest of
the ncis team that he killed the suspect
all except abby furious with mcgee abby
is convinced that the dog who she
affectionately renames jethro did
nothing wrong and she risks her career
to prove his innocence in 2019 a comment
thread titled what the hell abby
appeared on the subreddit for ncis a
community which hosts over 12 600
members as of 2022 a user took umbrage
with an early scene in the episode
during the scene in question abby
berates mcgee when she learns he shot
the dog and doesn't believe him when he
tries to explain the severity of the
attack while the commenter felt that
abby meant well they also claimed that
the dog almost tore mcgee's arm off and
gave him a lifelong fear of dogs but she
doesn't show the slightest bit of
sympathy to her friend and she never
apologizes numerous other redditors
affirmed that abby's treatment of mcgee
made little sense considering the
character's existing professional and
personal relationships another user
commented on the thread saying that abby
forces more like threatens mcgee to
actually contribute for flowers for the
dog and later forces him to take him in
as a pet another commenter referred to a
scene where abby tells mcgee sometimes
you have to look at the reality in front
of you and just accept it the user
points out the irony of these words
since abby doesn't follow her own advice
despite mcgee telling abby the truth
about what happened they exclaim this
dog she just med is more important than
her friend co-worker and ex-lover
general consensus seems to be that even
though abby eventually proves the dog's
innocence that doesn't mean mcgee should
have to adopt a semi-hostile animal who
attacked him in fact numerous fans
revealed how abby's attitude in this
particular episode started her
transformation into a selfish petulant
person they didn't enjoy watching an
august 2021 post on the ncis subreddit
includes a comment from a user who wrote
cracked and dog tags are the
quintessential abby is a petulant child
just cuz episodes just a few months
earlier an entire thread dedicated to
dog tags popped up on the ncis subreddit
the user wrote at length about how the
entire episode made them dislike abby
they voiced distaste for abby's highly
unprofessional attitude when the time
came to surrender the dog and went on to
detail their distaste for how abby
completely neglects mcgee's feelings the
post elicited a comment from another
user that appears to best sum up the
entire issue with dog tags and the way
it depicts abby i always loved early
season's abby but as the show progressed
i felt like she got more selfish
childish and unprofessional it was a
weird regression like they tried too
hard to make her quirky check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about ncis are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]